best piece of nice I got was really just
to do it when you're young especially
you have very low risk and it looks
great on a resume if you fail even
actually that you gave it a shot so my
family my friends telling me to just go
for it was really important my name is
Mitchell shamoto I'm the co-founder and
CTO of Hofstra Corp and I'm 27 years old
every company out there is delivering
software these days it doesn't matter if
you're a vehicle company or a lawnmower
company or a bank you're delivering
applications and so we're trying to make
that more efficient for you
[Music]
ha she means bridge in Japanese and when
we were going over company names me my
co-founder he we both really latched
onto the idea of we think that software
dumps people into a future without
giving them a way to get to that future
and so we we wanted our company to also
build bridges to the future not just be
like this is a shiny new thing good luck
getting there I think what makes us
unique is really the human aspect of our
software our users generally describe
our software as enjoyable to use and
that's not something you usually hear
with IT software or anything a lot of IT
software is made for for computers and
we like to think that our software is
made for people
[Music]
I had a good job offer up in Seattle
which is where I went to school and I
decided to move to San Francisco without
a job offer just because I figured I was
young I was a married or anything and if
I didn't do it now I probably wouldn't
be able to so easily move ever again and
that ended up just also being one of the
most important things with it
[Music]
we had any success and mine included
there's a lot of failures and for a
solid year our first piece of software
just wasn't used by anybody that is
before we had a company I kept working
on it cuz I loved it but I was pretty
pessimistic about it ever becoming a
thing and because of that failure I
started to just look into new
opportunities and I put Begaren as part
of my resume and one of the people I
talked to actually sponsored me to go to
local conferences and talk about it and
downloads went way up
so without vagrant not getting downloads
I wouldn't have eventually been able to
get the downloads that I needed to
motivate me eight years later to start a
company
[Music]